as we get ready for baseball with zach
ricky on the mound he's facing his
former team the arizona diamondbacks
hasn't faced them since 2015 since he
played with the d-backs from 2016
through 2019 at the trade deadline and
here's who
he will see josh rojas one of the guys
involved in the trade
at the top of the lineup back-to-back
change-ups and we're underway with a
strikeout for zach grenky
that one looked good well i was just
saying how about martin's probably
saying right now i'll just set up down
the middle you just make the pitch okay
that one out over the middle of the
plate and christian drives it into left
center
and walker will take a big turn at first
and hustle back there
the two out single for christian
this ball bobbled and off the glove of
nick ahmed
here's a guy who has led all shortstops
since 2018 and defensive run
saved and he is handcuffed by the first
ground ball tonight brantley gets into
one towards center field going back
marshall still at the wall leaping up he
can't make the play
springer will get to third and be held
up there is a visitor for omar lopez the
bases
are loaded might be one of the longest
singles of michael brantley's career
alex bregman struck out looking and now
0-2 on tucker
that one bounces away here comes
springer george is going to be
safe at home played as he runs into the
umpire who makes the safe call mike
mcclinsky
as george goes in head first to make it
one nothing
got to be aggressive on the base pass
like george was right there when you're
not scoring a lot of runs you got to
take advantage of
any opportunity and this one barely
kicking away
and george diving in there wow
finger tipped backing frankie because
here's what frankie said pointed to his
rib
coming to get you another good laugh
gotham looks a little uncomfortable
though because he doesn't really know is
zach being serious or not
and he gets peralta swinging as he got
ahead of the count and puts him down on
strikes three strikeouts out of the
first four outs for grinke
it's not typical zach cranky but we like
it swing
and a miss got him on a two-seamer down
and away
and smith down on strikes two in the
inning
michael bradley down the line and left
everybody was shifted to the right side
shortstop
ahmed was towards the middle of the
diamond so bradley had a wide open left
side of the infield and took advantage
trying to bring up kyle tucker kyle
tucker with a rbi base hit off the wall
in left field going the other way
both michael brantley and kyle tucker
with opposite field hits tucker a double
to score altuve
and it's a two to nothing astros lead
well there we go big
that one hit sent into left center van
meters aboard
and a single starts the d-back sports
there's one through the right side van
meter will stop at second walker's two
for two
and the d-backs down two nothing has
something going in the fourth
here comes cole calhoun call calhoun a
fastball down the middle
and say goodbye call calhoun
blasts off in houston and it's 3-2
diamondbacks
oh is he hot that's only the sixth home
run given up all year by zach grinky
oh yeah drop it in there at 62.
special stuff from zach grinky there is
a swing and a foul tip caught by
maldonado well zach frankie's up to
eight strikeouts two away in the fifth
there's a ground ball and gets by altuve
into center field for a basic with two
outs for ross
the 2-2 swing and a miss got him on the
curve ball
and bounce maldonado picks it out and
tags out van meter
the end against nine strikeouts for
grinky that ties a season high
springer leading off here with the
bottom half of the fifth inning against
zach allen
george hits one high and deep to left
field this ball
is gone up on the train tracks
the four train has just left union
station
to tie the game at three
that throws the bat at that one and can
he beat it out
now duvet can't make a play at nick's
aboard
talk about an emergency swing david
smith hits one deep to right center
field
that ball is off the wall it's off the
warning track out there here comes ahmed
david smith flying into third and has
got an rbi
triple they have insisted time and time
again that the power the
elevation the launch angle from haven
smith is on its way
they've seen it and that was a great
example right there he got almost all of
that one
even that one is going to get him home
it's off the plate make it 5-3
marshall smokes one into right field
dalton will
take the turn and head for second got a
hustle in there he's got a double
the kids are all right baby smith with
the rbi triple varshall the hustle
double
chris calhoun cole's handy a big hit
tonight
sends this one out to right field cole
calhoun
has hit another one it's over the head
of josh reddick cole
calhoun his second multi-home run game
on this road trip
and the diamondbacks have a 6-3 lead
on the ground to third van meter spins
and throws
three easy outs for stefan creighton the
houston native back in town and the
diamondbacks behind
two more home runs from cole calhoun
beat the astros six to three nice clean
ninth inning right there didn't have to
throw a lot of pitches
obviously be available tomorrow if the
d-backs have another save opportunity